bằng hóa tương, bị bản thay gió, nhưng qua ca mê ra giám sát,
biển số xe chỉ là một vệ tráng lã.
Dương ngày 12 tháng 3, lỗi này có thể bị phạt đến 2 mệ sảo sự đồng,
với ô tô, và sảo sự đồng với xe máy,
cục nhiều thay đổi khác nữa, để mức phạt, cục thay giá sáo.
Thay đổi đồng tiên là về biển số xe.
Chức này, các lỗi không đàn đủ biển số,
giám xa bị chi hoặc quý cách, để biển số bị mơ,
chia khốt, mẹ công, hoặc đặc đọc làm thay đổi chữ,
số, mộ sắc, hình giạc, khi thước,
hình giảm thay sảo sự đồng với ô tô,
và mộ biển số xe máy.
Dương từ ngày 12 tháng 3, nghĩ định mới,
hổ xung thêm hành đi, sự dụng chất liệu,
làm thay đổi khả năng dệ dịch thông tin,
biển số xe, khủng xe bị phạt.
Dí dụ như, bạn không được dụng phim phản quan,
là phủ khai là thiết bị giây loa ca mê ra,
để chè biển số khỏi hệ thậm giám sát,
dù mắt thường vẫn nhìn thấy gió.
Học nhau khuy định,
ô tô và xe máy trên dụng sẽ thay gản thay biển số,
một tí thước ngắn, một chăm sóm mươi lắm,
dành bà chăm bà mời biê mẹ và một biển kích thức dài,
một chăm mùi, dành về cạnh năm 2020,
lụi với mô tô,
gản mốt biển vệ xấu xe,
tí thước một chăm mùi mùi,
dành một chăm xì mùi biê mẹ.
Bình số khai là mọi người hợp kým nhau,
có mạng phản quan,
một phản quan,
và ký hiệu bỏ mật công an hiệu,
đồng chim giòn nét.
Chữ và số,
phải được bú chỉ cân đối,
gió dàng,
bình số phải gắn lúc bị chỉ tiếp kế,
không bị mơ,
không,
có bị chế khóc,
ngoài mất phát tiền,
tài xe sẽ bị chữ sấu nền,
ở trên dây phép lại xe,
và cơ quan chức năng,
sẽ tịch thủ,
kết bị làm thay lộ biển số,
kế theo là về quy định trở và kế lệu dối vải.
Tài xe trở và kế lệu dự vải,
nả,
bùn,
phay thải,
hoặc hàng dời,
nể dơi vải,
hoặc đến lước trạng dùng,
sẽ bị phản thay kế lệu dự vải,
theo quy định mới,
tư nhất,
một sự tật lệu dự vải,
đà mùn,
vào đảo dọng hàng,
và bị xưa vải,
còn lúc trước,
chỉ vông đất,
nả,
phay thải và hàng dời,
thứ 2,
mỏ điều kiện,
phải gây mất ăn tọn giáo thông,
mới bị phát.
Này xí cần đề dơi vải,
hoặc lúc trạng dùng đường,
là đủ,
để cạnh cứ xưa vải.
Tế theo là về việc lóc,
camera ở trong quan hành khách,
tư nhất,
với xe kinh dân tà hành khách,
từ tâm chỗ trở lên,
không tìm gây tài xe,
ngoài camera tài xe như trước,
này phải lóc thêm camera giám sát,
quan hành khách,
camera tài hoạt động bình thường,
và không được làm sai lệu dự lượng.
Tài xe vi vải sẽ bị phát mốt,
đến 2 xe đồng,
át dụng từ kế mục hộ tháng 1,
khách, in không chấp 2,
thì vải còn 2 năm dưới,
đến trình bị thử 2,
thì liện mới,
mở giọng ra các xe vật tải nữ bộ,
xe của các lớn đi,
giúp để vận xe đối bộ,
không thu tình gức cũng phải lóc camera để gây tài xe,
nếu vi vải chủ xe là cã nhân sẽ bị phát,
năm đến 6 xe đồng,
chủ xe là tổ chức sẽ bị phát môi,
đến 1 xe đồng,
quy định này có hiệu lực từ ngày 1 mốt tháng 1,
hành hình cũng trận 2 mỉ tám,
ngoài ra còn một số mốt phát môi khác,
cầm về lưới,
người lại ổ tổ biển trắng,
không ngang kỳ kinh dân tài,
nhưng chở khách có thu tiền,
nhận đặt chỗ,
họ kỳ hợp đồng sẽ bị phát môi hay,
đến 1 xe đồng.
Người này ổ tổ chở trẻ,
giữ môi tôi,
cao dưới 1 xe đá mê làm mét,
không dùng tiếp bị ăn tòn của hợp sẽ bị cạnh gáo,
còn nếu tài xe đẻ trẻ 1,
không hành hề lấy,
chủ xe chỉ có một hành gế,
sẽ bị phát trắng trắng trắng đến 1 xe đồng.
Tài xe xe hợp đồng,
đi tạm quy định về hợp đồng,
xanh xe khánh khách,
họ chở người ngoài xanh xe,
vẫn bị phát 1 xe đồng,
đến mới là bị định,
nạn thích xó hợp đồng giấy,
và hợp đồng đẹp tự,
thay vì gục trung như trước.